no question the cannabis industry is
ahead of almost every other industry
because of its general youth and
purebred entrepreneurship you got your
perspective don't you want to be happy I
love starting with the macro and then
going into the micro you know I my
college friends are gonna laugh their
asses off that I'm on the cover of your
magazine because literally their
four-year quest in college was to get me
to smoke a blunt with them right so this
is very this is this is an unbelievably
deja vu for me I grew up not drinking
beer or wine or alcohol yet I became an
unbelievable expert in at 15 17 19 21 23
on the consumer of that product right so
I'm like it's unbelievable to me in the
macro that it's so obvious that the
cannabis industry is heading in an
incredibly interesting consumer place
over the next half century and I'm not
in a rush to make predictions or know
everything just yet because this is a
real marathon for me I'm 42 years old
and I think that some of my most
intriguing thoughts or observations or
accomplishments within the industry
literally may happen in 30 or 40 years
so you're both yourself know what I'm
sorry yeah they are they're pretty young
actually my they're 64 and 62 so they're
young what will they think about you
being on the cover of a cannabis
magazine you know my mom was super
propaganda doubt by Nancy Reagan so she
was super hardcore like say no to drugs
and so yeah I think look I think my
parents know first of all the great
thing about my parents is and I just
spent a week with them because of
vacation they're very thoughtful meaning
like I genuinely believe with my heart
and soul that cannabis is a far better
thing for so many human being
than a lot of the things that are legal
in the United States right on a federal
level and so my parents are thoughtful
that way they can get my mom can get
caught up in the stigma of it Mike I
think right now if you actually like
lie-detector test me here's what I would
say my mom would be like hmm and my dad
would be like he's a genius that's gonna
work out which is really interesting
because that would be literally the
opposite of almost everything else my
mom is my greatest cheerleader and
thinks I'm a genius but I definitely
think I'm telling you Nancy Reagan got
to her well maybe one smart lady did it
well no question so at some point before
2012 you have the realization that
corporate America was slow to pick up on
content strategy trans-canada who's
making a similar mistake uh no actually
I think cannabis from my observation
early on is really good at it because
you have such young entrepreneurs who
are native to that communication I think
the platform's Facebook Google and such
don't let them advertise in all the ways
they wish they could but actually I
think the cannabis industry is going to
be the teacher of innovation to a lot of
the cannabis industry the way of you
Proctor and Gamble and coca-cola
consumer packaged goods and I think that
from you know obviously depending on
what happens at a federal state level
but I think they're going to innovate
and show the I mean I'm very comfortable
making this prediction in 2040 cannabis
companies are gonna be the ones
influencing the way diapers and tires
and soda and shampoo is being sold so
you often say that people aren't
marketing in the year that they live in
Indiana
companies lying to market your brand and
2018 and beyond
well you know again they can't run the
paid advertising on Facebook and YouTube
that I want them to so it's about
influencer marketing and organic
creative within the Facebook's Instagram
snapchats
of the world the end and I'll be I'll
say this again no question the cannabis
industry is ahead of almost every other
industry because of its general youth
and purebred entrepreneurship you said
the one thing that scares the [ __ ] out
of you are nice walkers and Salome what
is one piece of advice you'd give this
fella was motivated by you know to
really create context around that
statement anybody who buys a nice watch
or a Ferrari or a big house because
they're disguising insecurity is my
great fear right using material things
to put a bandaid on your emotional
shortcomings is very scary
and so my piece of advice is figure out
that buying a $900 supreme backpack
isn't gonna trick the smartest people
and I was watching that I've been doing
yourself by Southwest ox last year maybe
it had even in 2016 and you often talk
about you know the marathon versus a
friend and a building a brand you know
it's more advantageous than you know
spreading your you're unlike focusing on
locations or trying to essentially grow
too big for your sources I haven't
carrying on I was like either more like
the immersive like branding and and what
advice you'd get and how people can do
it well you know I think you and I share
this and I would I
lying if I didn't tell you that I'm
aware of a lot of the people that are in
the industry and that my voice is
uniquely beneficial to this industry
because you have an enormous amount of
people in the industry right now that
are so obnoxiously short-term right that
yeah you want your forefathers to be
good right because then you have a
healthier industry and so it's funny I
look at emerging markets whether it's
you know the emerging gambling market
that we're gonna see because of the
Supreme Court ruling cryptocurrency
cannabis what happens in these markets
is oftentimes you get you know three to
four percent pioneers and 96% hucksters
right and there's a there's an obnoxious
amount of hucksters in the cannabis
industry now a because they just love
smoking weed and I think it's they're
gonna be [ __ ] the Mark Zuckerberg of
weed or two because they see it as like
a trend that they want to they want to
like cash in fast you know to me it's
very simple it's it's it's as simple as
this life is actually a marathon
wouldn't it be a good idea to train for
a marathon you know it's that framework
like be patient don't like don't like
invest all your money on something that
seems like this is the great you know
this new formation of cannabis or hemp
is gonna be like people are chasing a
lottery ticket instead of thinking about
what I want them to think about which is
you have a ton of 24 year olds in the
industry thirty year olds and saying
okay I'm gonna be in this for twenty
years twenty years how am I gonna do
that right and so that's what I do right
like I vaynermedia is now in year nine
I've only really run it for seven years
I've always thought about it long term
and now it's you know nine hundred
people and now it's you know hundreds of
millions of dollars in revenue and now
it's a big thing but a lot of people
that started companies in 2009 through
eleven with me my homies were Silicon
Valley and others even though they
raised million
millions and millions of dollars their
companies are out of business now
short-term thinking and and this
industry is in the same way that the
cannabis industry over indexes on really
progressive marketing it also over
indexes on unbelievable
impatience and way too many people doing
it for the lifestyle not for the
business you thought you write you've
got Auto you've got video I don't think
for me personally a person is just you
know my perspective the this industry
has done a very good job of any of those
things and so weird what would you like
to see I mean I'm an investor in this
arena now that you know you're working
you just got ownership in Green Street
what would you like to use in this
review as far as you know writing and
audio video to educate sort of the
masses and to get people to realize what
what Canada is all about you know
because different things for different
people there's two things that aren't
happening to your question one there's
just not enough people creating they're
not doing they're not [ __ ] working
and and number two they're being too
ideological and romantic instead of
speaking truths I'm one of the most
popular entrepreneurs in our current
society no question like super proud of
that accomplishment I also find it
intriguing that I'm probably the one
that talks most about the shortcomings
of entrepreneurship and how many fake
entrepreneurs there are I'm not getting
high on my own supply you're not I'm not
you know I think I think I'm being
critical and thoughtful about the game
and I think that one of the things I see
in the cannabis industry is that no
matter what conversation I have with
somebody about it
they're on Team cannabis without seeing
any other part of it right it's like
blah it's blind buy-in so what I would
say is more work
and more articles and audio and video
output and and more authentic
conversations like what are you like
actually thinking not what's in the best
like do you know many people are just
saying things that are in the best
financial interest of them in the short
term to many most people legalize
cannabis they voted for it they did so
under the eyes it was convalescing right
and so are we living up as a community
and as an industry and as a you know
certain new industry are you living up
to the promises did we put forth and it
will be it will be very interesting to
sort of put people house in hot water
and happen the hard questions
I think I think you're you're gonna
you're gonna bring you I wish you could
see the size of my smile right now I'm
so proud of you guys because it's very
hard to be in a early to be in an
industry that's this young and not just
become the press release for the people
in it but what you're actually gonna do
is actually bring value to it I mean I'm
telling you right now my creative
curiosity my entrepreneurial curiosity
and the fact that I know I can bring
real tangible value to this industry is
the only reason you and I are talking
right now I mean I think I've listened
do a lot of your videos and your
podcasts that are out there in
interviews and I think they definitely
got them in a day I'm so sure I keep
hearing you say II don't like being you
know sort of peg
holidays for a guru or motivational
speaker why is that and why not that's a
great question I don't want that because
it's not the truth
right I spend 85% of my time being an
executive of a 900 person for office
company and I I think it's important
because I only think the truth wins and
so that's number one number two the
reason I don't is because I respect
execution too much and I think that only
being a speaker only being an author
only being a pundit is pontificating and
not doing and I love to pontificate as
my extracurricular activity to my actual
doing I also am even more excited than
my pontification 'he's come from the
outputs of my doing very simply I think
it's a lot better to take advice from
somebody who's done the thing they're
[ __ ] talking about well yeah right
like it's super hard for me to get fired
up about a 20 year old life coach when
they live 20 years it's super [ __ ] I
have a lot of cynicism for somebody who
writes a business book when they've been
a professor at Yale their whole lives
he's talked a lot about empathy and
further compassion right and not sort of
giving up thoughts of what other people
think of you
sophistical you always say like just
hearing what would you love what you
what do you say to someone who is
constantly very aware of like what other
people think and for the subscribe to
that like ideology of sort of
people-pleasing it's the best very hard
online by to me I think the only way you
get anybody out of any mindset is to
paint pictures for them to look at that
are different
the pictures that they're looking at and
so for me I'm on this constant mystic
mission to make people understand the
quickest way to be unhappy in life is to
let somebody else dictate your emotions
and and the truth is the people that
dictate your emotions tend to be the
people that are closest to you starting
with your parents right I mean it's just
[ __ ] real like I mean are you kidding
me like everybody's issues everybody's
issues is what their parents like all of
them like you know like obviously not
every single person but I'm talking like
I don't know 90 something percent I mean
it's a real thing you know um I went and
one way when I did I read about you you
weren't critique the creative right for
they're necessary and you know we need
people that are creative and then we
need sort of you know tough people so to
speak but when it might I mean we're in
the creative industry what we do have a
magazine there isn't one single person
here be the other than a financier
Daniel isn't created what invite you to
be creative in 2018 the other option
yeah make more stuff be less subjective
recognize that your ego and your power
trip is the reason that you're trying to
be perfect or spending too much time on
stuff we live in a world where we can
get instant feedback we can create a lot
more content there's a lot more
distribution wrap your head around it
you can't be a creative that lives in
the subjectiveness of your own point of
view otherwise you'll become obsolete in
the environment we now live in we don't
know well I mean first of all they're
not working I mean I love the New York
Jets more than breathing so you know 16
Sundays during the fall winter I love
that I'm a weirdly passionate
Seiler like literally no joke one of the
things that is most fun to me in the
world is to go garage saling and buy
[ __ ] for like a dollar and then flip it
on eBay for nine there's no word house
I like documentaries I like playing
basketball and tennis I like I love
spending time with my family like
uncomfortably love that
[Music]
if your wife who's like no that's the
thing that she thinks is like the most
annoying about you what would it be like
leave your dream box on the floor yeah
it would be like typical [ __ ] husband
[ __ ] right like I'm not paying attention
I'm not like it like I don't throw out
the trash like dumb [ __ ] cliche [ __ ] I
think I mean I mean look I travel a lot
you know so that's real you know but I'm
yeah I mean like I'll tell you another
thing like no joke I I didn't answer it
this way cuz I feel like it was a little
too cliche but then I'm always drawn to
the truth because I always think it wins
you can't imagine how [ __ ] fun my
professional life is to me you
understand I'm a purebred entrepreneur
for real for real for real like
documented lemonade stands baseball
cards DNF student long before this
entrepreneurship thing was cool like I
was on it it was me it's who I was and I
lived the first 20 years of my life
scrutinized by adults outside of my mom
and dad who said I wasn't good and I
wasn't gonna make it
instead of entitlement I I was brought
up in adversity which became my strength
I was told that I lost from the get by
every adult outside of my parents so
imagine how easy it is for me to deal
with adversity and negativity and
trolling and setbacks and pressure it's
the [ __ ] dirt that I come from so I
read that yeah the lemonade stand
baseball card thing
that's on you and you said that you
focus more on making good lemonade stand
signs and you did I'm actually making
good lemonade yes and not accustomed to
what you do at there me yeah no that was
that was a young Gary that it took me a
long time but but I will say this I will
say this I'm gonna answer it a couple
ways no three you know from over the
last 37 years or 35 years since then I
realize the best product is a very good
way to go however I've also learned that
only the customer gets to decide what
the best product is now how many cups of
sugar do you like in your lemonade right
I mean exactly right so so I think that
it's both and I think that learning that
was really good
does that make sense yeah so listen
you're gonna be on the cover art of our
technology issue
it's our inaugural it's the first one
we've ever done and in that vein I mean
tech like what is something that you
would like our audience to read on our
first ever tactic a shield you mean like
what else should I swear we're asked
should you guys look to like fill out
the issue there yeah you should
definitely focus on podcasting and audio
it's very very real the other thing is I
do think a lot of the advancements in in
the industry have been around the the
units that are delivering the cannabis
so I think there's been a lot of
innovation in that I think that's a very
good place for you guys think about like
10 best delivery mechanisms wherever you
want to cut if they call it you know I
think I love that I would tell you
there's a lot to do there design of the
of the hardware around the industry I
think is very interesting even the even
the containers in which the cannabis is
being delivered now right like it drops
and what forms I think there's a lot of
Technology
that people don't realize and then yeah
yeah just like the vapes and all that
you know all that just to like the
delivery mechanisms right and so I think
there's a lot to him to do there and
then I would say I would definitely do
something on like 25 best influencers on
the Instagram around the industry who
aren't hucksters right you know just
being thoughtful and bringing and maybe
it's a 9 or 7 hey guys I actually I've
got a little bit of an emergency I've
been holding off for like 10 minutes if
you need more from me I'm happy to do
another call later in the week I'll have
my team set it up but I've really got to
run I apologize okay thank you guys take
care bye bye
you